let's record this [ __ ] nobody who do you
think a little Sam Oh buddy yeah let's
get into rap I got a lot of rap things I
want a nice guys need to talk about this
dude man because personally yeah
personally mm-hmm
my my little old opinion mm-hmm I
[ __ ] hate the kid okay I really do
okay I hate him okay um I just think
it's so funny how much he's like been
memed recently yeah it's like the
kissing thing yeah everything is funny
first of all I I guess like I should go
back into into why I hate him
yeah there's a bunch of [ __ ] where he
you know he's like really really full of
himself
yeah he's one of the dudes I think I've
said this before but he's constantly
like preaching positivity yeah you know
in any interview is like I'm just here
for the kids man preaching positivity
and I'm all about positive miss and
whatever and and then like you know
he'll he'll like he'll call some what a
[ __ ] in the same sentence yeah he'll be
like if you're not positive you're a
[ __ ] yeah like food sensing well yeah
exactly the fouseytube
right yeah yeah exactly he's also sure
there's like it's right go ahead another
fentanyl thing yeah so there's like
screenshots of him
like bragging about selling fentanyl
boys selling laced pills and hooked and
all this [ __ ] in Swedish wishing death
on people it's old you and he's like you
know yeah okay he was like pretty [ __ ]
up over little peeps death and then I
don't know the [ __ ] oh yeah seems
like a bad kid yeah when he [ __ ] he like
Photoshop that picture with him and peep
mm-hmm and it's like they had never done
anything together just like such like
such a weird [ __ ] thing to do man
yeah I'm not gonna I mean and you know
maybe I'm not 100 percent correct on
this right maybe he is a good kid I
don't know my impression so far is that
and like the clips I've seen of him it's
that he's a piece of [ __ ] basically
right so it was very very funny for me
to read this he was he was like dating
Noah Cyrus was Miley Cyrus's sister and
they broke up and he was like on
livestream they had a song together and
a video was supposed to come out and he
comes on livestream and goes the video
is not coming out of him
we broke up blah blah blah getting Jesus
yeah he's I'm getting used all this
stuff he's like I'm always a victim like
I'm always getting used my whole life
and so people are like what don't know
what the [ __ ] happened she was just
playing him like something anyways then
I read this tweet that says Noah Cyrus
takes to her Instagram story to reveal
little Zen broke up with her after she
sent this meme of Charlie Truths head on
a porn stars body
it's a screenshot of her story where she
screeched outed a text with him yeah and
it's just Charlie puth and its job naked
with a giant eggplant emoji in front of
his dick yeah and so she sent that to
him and just said Charlie puth poof
whatever he goes why did you send that
pic what the [ __ ] nerd caption is I'm
heartbroken and confused this is the
meme I sent Diego that made him think
I'm cheating dude this is so good no no
not then he um
then he tried to correct it cuz like her
last picture is her like hugging up on
some other dude and he's like this is
the picture that made me do it
you wouldn't be touching other dude like
that if he was my girl and all this [ __ ]
it was like nah man brah
I think if my girl sends me a naked
Charlotte poof meme he's over not
relationship ended I love why would you
send me that no question mark why would
you send me that now I'm hard why did
you send me this is exactly why I don't
look at gay porn now yo bro get over
here this one my girl who sent me
waiting this means dude it's like a meme
it's like funny yeah this is funny this
is not funny why would you send me this
[Laughter]
just like I'm [ __ ] dead and those led
to humor no why would you send me this
what is this garbage honestly honestly
grow up grow up
and working who is this man I don't even
charge
Charlie puth who is that I don't even
know who that is
it's like a big pop star what's pop
what's pop I don't it's not even him man
it's like a Photoshop double [ __ ] his
Photoshop what do you think I'm a
scientist
what does Photoshop you think I'm a
weatherman just trying to invert
scientists and weatherman what is this
[ __ ] garbage what is this I'm in a
very serious meeting okay me little
teardrop and a boogie down be baller and
on foot I'm down challenge I'm trying to
think of like shitty rap name boogie
down challenge yeah boogie down
challenge 3 Royale yeah it's another one
yeah no clip to rear oh yeah we gotta
have like a gun reference in there okay
yeah clip three Royale wavy chop oh you
got always got to take like drug dealer
names yeah right yeah right or uh you
know Trevor young Trevor
yeah we got a we got a big serious
meeting right now and how dare you send
me I don't even know who this Photoshop
Charlie puth guy is is so good what do
you think it was real
yeah what's a witch like like what it
what is like the path of logic in his
head that she's cheating on him because
like what was she what was she meaning
to do send a naked picture to the guy
that she's you know cheating with of him
yeah wow you look so good here I found
this pic of you online
wow wow look at this thanks for this
nude I'm gonna send it right back you
look I put it I she's no she was sending
it to him cuz she put the eggplant on it
but she didn't know how to save it right
so she had to like send it to him to
like save it to her phone say I want to
send this to my friends I don't don't I
want them to see your dick I wanna send
this to my boyfriend but I don't want
him to see your dick let me send this to
you
oops sent to him already yeah that's
what I'm imagining Diego goes yo what
the [ __ ] did you take this are you
cheating on me she's like no it's a no
he's already on livestream yeah I just
beginning used like it hurts so [ __ ]
bad like I just keep getting used all
right to power moves I just thought of
right now go right one of them is
sending someone's nudes back to them
right after they send them to you edited
or uninhabitable Power Move unedited
just back just back that's actually
pretty far yeah that's a Power Move 100%
because it's like semi zombie bags like
alright second Power Move that's
depressing
oh man you said it dick pic and you just
get it sent right back and then she goes
what you think you're like oh my god
Power Move do I remove no mass is a
Power Move number two is when you're
like when you're when you have like an
epiphany or something maybe you're like
having a conversation with someone and
you make like a big decision yeah you
come to a realization or whatever or
whatever pop up the live stream right
there and say to the live stream in
front of them well don't say to them
yeah don't say to them you know like so
you think about breaking up with your
girl or whatever she finally you know
the tipping point comes she says
something you're like that's it it's
over
sorry guys relationship ended well what
the [ __ ] I'm right here you didn't give
me a chance go throw some owls in the
chat for Janet here's everything why did
I take the El [ __ ] you cheated yeah I
cheated on you because you suck and her
[ __ ] she's a [ __ ] you guys
relationship ended peace telling someone
to put l's on someone's picture is so
wack now cuz only
[ __ ] I've got some clothes yes I got
some clothes I got some clothes
these are custom foam
these are